hello everyone thanks for having me here
um welcome to my talk on making shiney
up deployments a little bit
easier so imagine you're a passionate
data scientist um you've got this great
idea for a shiny up and you're like
right okay let's go ahead and make
it so you spend a bunch of time uh
creating your app on your development
machine and you might spend some days uh
weeks maybe even months in some cases
and you're really looking forward to the
end result and that's a valuable shiny
app um something that's super useful uh
something that could be maybe used in a
business
context um yeah so you have your VI app
and it runs super smoothly on your
machine locally and it's Testament to
God that's an awful picture um all the
hard work that you've put in um so now
comes the moment when you want to gift
your creation to a wider audience that
means thinking about
deployment so if you're using posit
connect it has a nice easy workflow for
deploying and managing apps uh it has a
great user interface it has this smooth
uh oneclick deployer functionality uh
the thing is that someone has to
maintain this platform
um if you don't want to maintain a
platform then shiny
app.io has a very similar workflow it's
maintained by posit uh you don't have to
worry about keep keeping the underlying
system updated uh but maybe a project
has restrictions on data
residency uh if you're a developer and
you don't care about any of this stuff
you might be in a company where you give
your code to another team and they might
look after the deployment and they might
come up with some solution uh using the
open source shiny server or shiny proxy
um there are a whole bunch of ways to
deploy a shiny up uh that's just a
couple of
them whatever deployment method you've
gone with uh on the the journey making
this up there's been a bunch of hurdles
that you've had to jump over and I guess
the final hurdle of that is deployment
so it would be a real shame if the app
fails to deploy because it' be like
falling at the final
hurdle so what can we do to help avoid
this well who's we in this question so I
like to think that there's two personas
involved in the deployment process now
this could be separate people it could
be two separate teams or it could be the
same person that does both sides and
sees the whole uh deployment process
from start to end uh so I like to think
that the first Persona is uh or a
developer so someone who writes code to
create applications they're responsible
for the design uh testing debugging uh
they work on functionality user
interface and
features and the other persona in the
process is uh it operations so these are
people who are responsible for setting
up deploying and maintaining
applications on servers
now uh
yeah they make sure it's popular
configured hosted and available for the
users so it could be possible that this
Persona looks after more than just
shiney ups and they could be maintaining
a platform that shiny UPS a deploy to
such as posit
connect so a little bit about me um I'm
someone who fits into this it operations
Persona I'm not much of a shiny
developer as you can probably tell I
don't uh develop shiny day to-day but I
know enough to make uh silly cat apps um
so yeah I'm in this it operations
Persona because of my role in this
company and that's uh jumping Rivers so
I've been with them just about two years
uh we offer all sorts of services
related to the data science Fields um we
offer training and a variety of topics
so primarily for R and python um but
things like stanit Scala um and
more so out of these topics like what I
specifically do um are probably these
three
things so in particular it's manage
posit services and infrastructure so
that's the service where we aim to take
the pain out of creating uh managing and
maintaining Cloud infrastructure and
data science tools that means that data
scientists can uh get with the problems
that matter most to
them uh so yeah I provide support to
customers who use those platforms
primarily through email and sometimes
video
calls so in this it Ops Persona uh
support and connect uh I sometimes get
queries from clients asking like hey can
you help me figure out uh why this app
doesn't work uh it works on my machine
um so yeah this this talk aim to briefly
skir over some of the uh more common
root causes that I've seen in my
role uh so how do you know when a car is
having problems uh if you turn the
ignition and it doesn't start that's
probably a pretty good uh indicator um
you might also see some warning lights
on your dashboard that's usually a sign
that something's
wrong um if you have a bit of knowhow uh
there are a bunch of things you can
check yourself under the hood of a
car um similarly with shiny up failures
um deployment logs give us a peak under
the hood of our deployment which might
reveal some information about uh why
it's not working so you can find
deployment logs in different places for
each method of deployment uh it's like
yeah the first Port call when you're
troubleshooting your apps uh so
for uh R Studio connect uh the
deployment logs nice and easy to find
it's in the top right corner um there's
this handy logs tab on shiny
ups. and sometimes you need access to
the server and the logs will be located
in something like the V log directory if
you haven't changed the
configuration so just like looking under
the hood of a car for the first time
looking at logs might be a little
intimidating at first uh they contain a
lot of text but there's
often there's often like telltale signs
and um if you know the sort of things to
look out for like uh connection errors
or resour spot onck or missing libraries
uh they can all be easy to spot log
messages so what are some common
pitfalls that I've
seen well a common Pitfall that I've
often seen uh stems from hardcoded
secrets so they're not great from a
security perspective um especially if
you're putting code into something like
a git
repository um if you imagine something
like a database password being put into
Source codes uh then you need to
remember to like remove the secrets and
then add them back in um it could be an
extra step that's sometimes forgotten so
this is an example uh database connect
with some credentials that might be used
for developing locally and this might be
uh what's required when you actually
deploy so unless you change the code
between each environment you're going to
get uh database connection
issues while this is bad from a security
perspective involv some extra effort it
doesn't necessarily cause deployments to
fail it's just yeah when you forget to
to change them between the
two so I'm going to go into some Niche
European driving laws um so in the UK we
drive on the left hand side um and this
is how our car headlights are configured
so basically the right hand side
headlight is dipped so that you don't
blind everyone in the oncoming
Lane uh now the rest of Europe drives on
the right I don't know why these
pictures are oriented this way I wish
they were just the same way slightly
annoying but that's where we are
um yeah as you might expect yeah the
lights are the opposite way around in
the rest of Europe so driving a UK car
uh in sayfe France without adjusting
your headlights is illegal cuz yeah
you'd be blind everyone uh some fancier
cars had the functionality to switch the
configuration at the price of a switch
and some other cars didn't have that
functionality and that meant they
couldn't easily adapt when you yeah say
went to France or something like
that uh so hardcoded variables kind of
limit the configurability at deployment
time uh to get this sort of European UK
car headlight switching capability uh
you can do this with your code um and
replace your variables with calls to
environment variables uh now this codes
could be committed to a git repository
and you won't be showing any sensitive
values um and yeah you don't have to
change the code between your Dev and
Broad environment so you might be
thinking where do you actually set the
values if not in the
code well here's posit connects it's a
little bit small but the section I want
to point out is on the right hand side
um and this is this uh vas Tab and this
is a section for setting environment
variables and here at the bottom we have
we already have our environment
variables already set they got the names
of the environment variables that were
in the
code uh when I click edit I can only set
a new variable it doesn't show the old
value uh the variables are stored
securely from other users of the
platform uh so this in particular is
good for things like personal API keys
and the
like now with shiny UPS to IO and shiny
server uh it's not quite a swish you
need to have this uh R environment file
in your app directory to set the
environment
variables um so environment variables
kind of like this point on environment
variables kind of leads me nicely into
my next point which is more there are CS
to this um actual problem which is the
availability of external resources so
just as cars need fuel to run uh yeah
probably relies on um external
data so you app might rely on apis that
allow external systems to communicate
and interact with the shiny
up you might pull uh data from a
database to populate some nice
visualizations similarly you might pull
resources from some sort of remote file
or something like
that if these resources aren't available
then your it's kind of like your apps
fuel source isn't available so some
common causes for this are things like
Inc incorrect credentials which I just
covered um it could also be things like
connectivity so and and things like
firewall rules so for example with shiny
apps. I in order to access a database
that's something that's like behind
something like a company firewall um you
need to whitel list some shiny ups. IO
um addresses in the firewall and you
need to ask a CIS admin or someone um
who is in charge of
that uh another thing I've come across
is permissions of the user in the
database uh so you want to ensure that
your database user that's specified in
the shiny application that has the
necessary permissions to perform the
operations these might be readon and if
you try and do a right operation in your
uh shiney up then obviously that's not
going to
work uh the next reason apps fa to
deploy is probably the most common and
it's issues with dependencies so
libraries packages and files that make
up your
application uh just as is a bunch of
parts that fit together to make up a car
uh it's crucial to ensure that you have
a clear understanding of the dependency
but your app requires and that they're
included in the deployment process uh so
yeah maintaining this like detailed car
parts list
um it's it's kind of like what it's like
and if something's missing and someone
wants to build a car from that car parts
list and something's missing then the
car's probably not going to work uh the
RS connect package and right manifest
function can be pretty helpful with
maintaining things like this so it's
great for our package dependencies and
files and but it doesn't help when they
rely on things like underlying system
dependencies so many our packages
contain code written in C or C++ for
performance reasons so if you use these
you need to have the development tools
installed on your deployment
environment uh certain packages might
need system utilities such as uh WG curl
or git to download data and interact
with external
resources uh if you plan on using our
packages for generating PDF documents um
you you need to have like a tech
distribution
installed uh qu seems to be all the rage
at the moment I'd love to know how to
use it um but my role doesn't really
stretch much more than installing it um
so yeah I think I've draw home that
there's this obvious point that if
something a dependenc is missing um
that's the reason the app doesn't
work uh so uh another critical
consideration is the resourcing on the
environment uh in which your apps
deployed so just as a Formula 1 car
needs a suitable engine to perform well
uh your shiny app needs appropriate
computing power uh and memory to operate
effectively so obviously a lack of uh
appropriate resources would lead to slug
performance it's kind of like imagine
this car had you know a small engine uh
it wouldn't uh perform as well in a
race uh yeah so system is resources uh
just how you can tune a car's engine to
run optimally um as a developer you can
tune your apps code to use uh few
operations or like CPU cycles and memory
I think Joe covered that pretty well in
the previous talk
um sometimes there's a platform
configuration settings related to memory
so there's this Max app image size um a
config setting in the connect settings
um so if your app uses large assets like
images and data files
um independencies and it exceeds this
total size and obviously it's not going
to work so collaborating with it
operations to ensure that y app's
deployment environment has the
appropriate resources and it's
configured correctly is vital for having
a successful
deployment uh so I'm going to quickly
touch on some proactive approaches you
can take um I don't have the time to
really go into them in any depth uh so
one effective approach is continuous
integration
and uh continuous deployment so that
involves automating the process of
deployment um so anytime Mak any code
changes it will um you know as with any
automation will save time you don't have
to redeploy it every time you make a
code
change uh so yeah this this will help uh
save
time uh another strategy is
containerization and that involves
packaging your app and its dependencies
into isolated environments and as
container
um this approach ensures consistent
Behavior across different environments
from like development to production so
like you can encapsulate like your
environment variables and things like
that all into the uh Docker container or
well I haven't even mentioned Docker yet
but that's that's a tool that you can
use for
containerization um yeah uh moreover
monitoring and alerting systems play a
pivotal role in Catching issues before
they escalate so uh yeah just as modern
cars come equip with sensors that you
know come up with lights on your
dashboard um monitoring tools can notify
you of things like yeah performance
anomalies or resource usage spikes um
and errors and you know alerts can help
you take uh action if like it reaches a
certain threshold or something like
that uh yeah so just to recap some of
the things I've covered in this talk um
if you can take away at least one thing
that I've mentioned um that you haven't
heard of before and you can do some
Googling around it then I guess I'll be
really
happy
um yeah and you can look out for it in
your next shiney up
deployment uh so yeah as I said like
logs will give good Clues and nowh to
find them is good knowledge to
have uh I went into hardcoded Secrets
probably a bit more in depth than the
others um but most often
um the different types of dependencies
either external or internal uh the main
reason why uh deployment will
fail so thanks for listening um so don't
got any questions uh I've got some
contact details on the right hand side
if you wanted to email me about anything
uh and we've got some blogs uh at the
link on the
bottom yeah thanks for listening
guys
[Applause]
we we do have time for a couple of
questions and your first question is do
you think there is anything that the
shiny uh library and posit developers
could do differently to make the
deployments
easier for it
administrators
um I
guess
so I'm a little uh yeah feel like a bit
of a de in headlights um can you repeat
the question
please sure so so the question is that
uh could the the shiny the developers
that create shiny that uh or posit
developers in general could do something
differently could they help you somehow
uh you know to make the deployments
easier uh I guess things like the the
man best um in like the IRS connect
package help make deployments a lot
easier
um yeah I guess like guidelines to
provide to developers and things like
that
um would be yeah B
beneficial okay you have second question
which is one thing that can be
frustrating is differences between Dev
and prod environments that do not raise
errors in the logs so do you have any
any tips for diagnosing these so and you
don't have any errors you know for the
dev environments in the logs but you do
for the for the production
environments um so well so I guess you
so you have errors in the logs for the
prod environment so I guess yeah looking
through the logs I guess scanning them
for keywords and maybe some of the sort
of bullet points that I've mentioned
um Google Google's a good uh
yeah Google's a good place to
look I guess one strategy is to make the
broad system as similar to the dep
system you know as possible then you
would catch these things earlier yeah
yeah that uh that's a pretty obvious one
yeah I guess I should have
said Okay so let's so let's thank all
the speakers of this
[Applause]
session